oh you did that today I'm in New York
and I'm gonna meet up with a band dnce
and together we're gonna let their
Twitter followers decide their day it's
gonna be lovely we're gonna have really
good time we're gonna dance oh we're
gonna dance
[Music]
hey how's it going hey I'm Keith nice to
meet you Cole
aqui Joe I'm you Jinju Jack all the way
over there nice to meet you thanks for
going to do this I know it's tough to
let Twitter decide everything you're
gonna do the whole day we'll send out
tweets are gonna decide what you do next
whenever you're first since we have such
a big day ahead of us it's got some
coffee right let's do it I can I get a
phone Can I grab a phone sir oh yeah Oh
fanny pack phone is the way to go
all right so I'm going to send out a
tweet real quick that we are getting
coffee let's say they'll have you choose
between singing your order helping clear
away people's garbage or buying a bunch
of coffee and handing it out so I'm
going to send this out we're going to
put five minutes on this poll there we
go now we wait
they chose Tana now coffee so guys give
out some coffee
thank you very much my buddy Ken you
guys want a free coffee but Phil want a
free coffee you want a free coffee it's
so good it's not good when you stand in
front of a coffee shot and asking if
people want coffee right there's a lot
of people come you want some coffee
yeah all right jinjoo gave away free
coffee free coffee all right y'all there
man right
I'm also in dnce I wanted to surprise
you
we're going to the Knicks game go to the
next game look yes get in the car we'll
do some more things from there we're
going to message we're Garden get in the
car get in the car get from the car
should we at intersections compliment
people sing to people or blow kisses
yeah let's do it
Oh people want to sing to people classic
Jin Joo has poor taste in man oh I gotta
say you have such a beautiful voice do
you not put him on his front vocals on
everything is it work it's beautiful
it's so good but we're almost to MSG so
I wanted to figure out what are you guys
going to do right and you get there you
know there's gonna be fans outside
we're headed to MSG when we get there
should we have people take our pictures
or do the Andy challenge how do you know
that's the Toy Story thing man oh it's a
2000 yeah we should draw Andy and then
drop Eddie's coming
we're good we're good am i good
everybody good am I good am I still toy
awesome okay great let's go over there
obviously incredible basketball over
here we have a special challenge Twitter
really wanted you guys to dance
specifically to new single body moves so
I got the Knicks City Dancers to meet
you to dance so we're going to tweet out
either that they're going to teach you
guys a new dance you're going to teach
them a new dance or nobody's going to
learn anything you're just gonna throw
down in a dance battle good let's do it
alright guys so turns out twitter
decided you'd have a dance battle let's
see how your body moves hit it
[Applause]
oh wow wow wow
synchronize avant-garde I have never
seen it before
viewer tremendous obviously you actually
won but for the purpose of the video
dnce won congratulations
great work are you guys hungry after
that or Nations need feel like oh my
gosh you worked up such a hunger I could
go for some 60 lets choose between all
the candy all the popcorn and all the
ice cream sound good love it and the
next thing you'll see is a slo-mo eating
gorgeous food god what is happening what
is happening
you
oh you good then
alright dnce I hate to say it but our
our time has drawn to a close we have so
much remains must come doing it they
really do they do all end but we don't
know how they end so I'm gonna send out
one final tweet asking Twitter how does
this video end a rom-com ending where
are they now
yeah a jump into a freeze frame or a
tearful goodbye and there we go and now
we wait now we wait five minutes okay so
I just got home and I was looking
through my phone to grab screen grabs of
all the tweets and I realized that the
one that I thought one the end of the
video didn't win I accidentally chose
the second-place winner but you know in
today's climate sometimes the popular
vote just doesn't win and you get what
you get
so here's what you get you're a big mean
glasses-wearing
sure no no no we saw you hanging out
with another band that's right how could
you do this to our heart wasn't like
that we're done we're done you don't
know [ __ ]
why are you gonna be that way to sign it
fine meter by me hey wait hey wait
Keith we were kidding I can still smell
you it's fine guys is gone
wait wait I can make it up
[Music]
they're really gone
by deity